defending taijuan.
>> I'll have that conversation
with him.
>> I actually have an unrelated
question, too.
Mr. President, do you think Elon
Musk is a threat to U.S.
National security and should the
U.S. And with the tools you have
investigate his joint acre
acquisition with Twitter and
foreign governments like the
Saudis?
[ Laughter ]
>> I think that Elon Musk's
cooperation and/or technical
relationships with other
countries is worthy of being
looked at.
Whether or not he is doing
anything inappropriate, I'm not
suggesting that.
I'm suggesting at worst being
looked at and -- and that's all
I'll say.
>> How?
>> There's a lot of ways.
All right.
Kristen Welker?
>> Thank you so much, Mr.
President.
I appreciate it.
I want to follow up with you on
working with Republicans.
Leader Mccarthy again suggested
that he is not prepared to write
what he says a blank check to
Ukraine and yet, you expressed
optimism that funding for
Ukraine would continue, that the
policies toward Ukraine would
continue.
Why should the people of Ukraine
and this country have confidence
in that given the comments by
leader Mccarthy and just to
follow up with you on your
comments to zeke, you said you
don't need to do anything
differently.
If Republicans control the
house, don't you need to
recalibrate to some extent to
try to work across the aisle
with the Republican led house?
>> Well, let me put it this way.
What I meant is I don't have to
change the policies that have
already passed.
That's what they said they want
to go after.
What I have is a simple
proposition.
I have a pen to veto.
That's what I mean.
I don't have to recalibrate
whether I'm going to continue to
fund -- we're going to continue
to fund the infrastructure bill
or we're going to continue to
fund the environment, et cetera.
We have to -- I hope -- there is
a growing pressure on the part
of the American people expecting
both parties and all elements of
both parties to work out their
substantive differences and not
just -- I'm not going to do that
because it would benefit that
party.
Just make it personal.
So I -- and, you know, it
remains to be seen what the
makeup of the house will be but